Küssen ist toll -
aber warum eigentlich?
Unsere Lippen gehören
zu den empfindlichsten Teilen
unseres Körpers.
Sie haben sogar
eine höhere Nervendichte
als unser Genitalbereich. - Wow!
Beim Küssen senden diese Nerven
Signale an unser Gehirn,
wo dann eine regelrechte Hormonparty
in unserem Belohnungssystem
gefeiert wird.
Tanz der Moleküle.
Wir stellen euch die Botenstoffe
vor, die Küssen so schön machen.
1. Oxytocin -
auch bekannt als das Kuschelhormon.
Stärkt
zwischenmenschliche Bindungen.
Es ist dasselbe Hormon,
das auch bei Mutter und Kind
während des Stillens
ausgeschüttet wird.
2. Dopamin -
wird bei allem ausgeschüttet,
was uns Spaß macht
und wirkt teilweise
ähnlich wie Kokain.
Suchtpotenzial und ein...
- Noch mal!! Noch mal! ... -Effekt
miteingeschlossen.
3. Serotonin -
ist wie Dopamin
bekannt als Glückshormon.
Ein Mangel an Serotonin
steht in Verbindung
mit Depressionskrankheiten.
4. Adrenalin -
sorgt für den achterbahnmäßigen
Rausch, der Puls steigt,
die Pupillen weiten sich -
schließen wir deswegen vielleicht
die Augen beim küssen?
5. Endorphine -
das sind Peptide,
die für Gefühle der Euphorie sorgen.
Der Name Endorphin
kommt von Endo-Morphin,
was so viel heißt
wie körpereigenes Morphin,
das berühmte Schmerzmittel -
küsst also eure Schmerzen weg.
Langfristig
senkt Küssen außerdem
die Produktion
des Stresshormons Cortisol.
Regelmäßiges
knutschen entspannt also.
Kennt ihr schon
unser letztes Video zum Küssen?
Teil 1 gibt es hier oder unter dem
Link in der Beschreibung.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)